welcome back to freestyle games i'm
jamie jackson so we wanted to tell you a
lot more about the rock star experience
you're going to get in Guitar Hero live
so you're going to be taken to the stage
as the lead guitarist for ten bands
across two festivals so the first
festival is sound dial and this is a
European festival set in the UK so we've
tried to kind of build something that
really embodies UK festivals rather
blocks a complete contrast to sound that
so it's set in the u.s. is set within a
city so these these stages are in
streets they're in city parks the crowd
are going to be completely different
we make atari alive by filming it all
live action you know we actually built
these stages you even went to people the
buildi stage is for festivals so super
authentic whereas before you know the
camera was down in amongst the audience
and it was looking up at the performers
rough on stage this time we've turned
the camera around so guitar hero life
offers this first-person experience we
wanted to give you that up-and-down
roller coaster experience of what it
feels like to be real lobster
so long side the festival experience
we've also got gh TV it's our first 24
hour seven days a week playable music
video network you're going to be able to
jump online whenever you want and
there's going to be music for you to
play you need we have to change channels
if you don't like the music you jump
into and on top of that you're going to
be able to play music on demand I mean
it's a totally new type of game but the
core of JH TV it's not just about
playing the game it's about discovering
music we're able to continually update
the schedule of songs that are playing
on the channels and update the list of
songs that are in the odds of our song
list so we'll be able to put new songs
and new material into the game but it
also allows us to listen to our friends
so you know we can see what they're
playing see what they enjoy and make
sure that they get more of that so we're
working with our partners in the music
industry in order to secure new music
content for our players so we've been
working with avenged sevenfold's have
some great stuff in the game for launch
so as well as the progression system
engaged live where you're going to be
getting crowd rewards and you're going
to be completing stages in GH TV there's
a huge amount progression as well I'm
going to be constantly running in-game
currency which is going to allow me to
buy new casaya skins is going to allow
me to get new gems it's going to allow
me to get new hero powers so as I hear
kind of level 10 maybe I'm going to
unlock rivals mode where I'm going to be
able to go up against other people and
take them on side by side
when we started thinking about tire life
knew we wanted to make a game that gave
everybody choice and there's something
for everybody and that kind of goes back
to the new controller layout you know
with 60 islands you've got that correct
depth to it but also music choice was a
huge thing for us to such a breakfast
music genres in there and then we also
wanted to Kate as a types of player now
we know we've got the tire a horrible
players that one of unlocked everything
canned 100% everything so that's there
for you engage live and TV but we also
know we've got those casual players they
just want to get together with mates and
just kind of jam out and they live in so
quit playing lives there for you or you
can totally get lost in church TV
because it's just so much content so
ultimately we wanted to make a game that
was fun and that's whether you're
playing single player on whether you're
playing with a bunch of masochism if
you've got two guitars you can just
bring the other one round plug it in and
you're gonna have local competitive play
and you can do that on JH TV and on life
and so there's a local multiplayer
experience but there's also an online
multiplayer experience to compete
against other players around the world
to be one of top thurs and ght be one of
the cool things about guitar hero was it
had singing and that's the same in
Guitar Hero live you can play microphone
in the note highways going to come
across the top of the screen and your
friends gonna be able to join in sing
the high up so this October you're going
to be able to get your hands on guitar
hero live you're gonna get guitar her
alive you're gonna get the new guitar
controller and you're gonna get access
to judge TV and we just can't wait to
see what you guys do with it
you
you